الجزيره العربيه وشبه الجزيره العربيه بما
فيها المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا جزيره
كما تعلم اخي العزيز مساحه اكثر من 3
مليون كم مربع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تحتل اليوم ايضا اكثر من 2 مليون مربع فهي
غنيه كثيرا
بالمراكز الحضاريه المتميزه والمدن
والدويلات المدن المعروفه والممالك التي
عاشت في همم في اطرافها وفي وسطها وفي
انحاء متفرقه من الجزيره العربيه الجزيره
العربيه الحقيقه عمقا تاريخي يعود الى الى
ملايين السنين ليست فقط الى الى فتره بنيد
او قبيله
لدينا ادله تعود الى العصور الحجريه
القديمه كالعصر الحجري القديم والعصر
الحجري الوسيط والعصر الحجري الحديث لدينا
الاف المواقع التي تعود الى هذه الفتره
التاريخيه تحديدا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وفي بقيه مناطق شبه الجزيره
العربيه هي طبعا الاكثر موجود الحقيقه في
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم وهذه
وهذه المواقع الاثريه همم الحقيقه صوره
صادقه لمكانه او لما قدمه انسان تلك
الفتره همم نيسان في الجزء العربيه همم
للجدار الحضاري
برجع دكتور على موضوع مداريك عن اعمال
الكشف والتنقيب الاثري في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه منذ ان بدات الى اليوم ندع هذا
الموضوع لكن اسال سؤال يمكن يكون مهم
لتعطير النقاش ما هي ب- بعد دراساتك همم
العديده ومضاعك لهذه السنوات في هذا الحقل
ابرز الحضارات التي نشات في الجزيره
العربيه وابرز الحضارات التي تشابكت من
خارج الجزيره العربيه مع هذه الحضارات
تشابه كتجاريه اجتماعيا ثقافيه لن نقول
ابرز الحضارات في الجزيره العربيه ولو
بشكل سريع
الجزيره العربيه غنيه في الواقعه
بالحضارات التي تعود الى كافه العصور
العصور الحجريه او العصور التاريخيه
اذا عدنا العصور الحجريه ايضا لدينا اخر
احصائيات اللي موجوده في همم عند همم هيئه
الاثار همم على الاقل تزيد على 10,000
موقع يعود العصور الحجريه كل هذه الحقيقه
تدل على الانسان في تلك الفتره مارس حياته
الطبيعيه في التقنيات المعروفه انا ذاك في
العصر الحجري وانت تعلم العصر الحجري
الحقيقه فتره طويله جدا يعني استمرت
تقريبا من ملايين السنين الى 120,000 سنه
قبل الميلاد كل هذه كانوا كانوا يسمونها
العصر الحجري هو مقسمي العده اقسام رئيسيه
الحجر الحجر العصر الحجري القديم ثم
المتوسط ثم المتاخر وكل هذه الاقسام همم
تبين ان الجزيره العربيه والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه من ضمنها انها الحقيقه لها نصيب
لا باس به ونصيب يعني كبير جدا من المواقع
التي تعود الى هذا عاصم مما يعني هذه
العصور كلها مما يعني ان الانسان الحقيقه
كان متواجدا في الجزء العربيه وادى دوره
او دور الحضاري